this is a vigil for Joe Cox who was
murdered today in her constituency doing
her job as an MP representing the area
she loved tonight her husband Brendan is
devastated and their two children have
lost a mum they'll never see again lost
somebody they can remember as a
wonderful woman who stood for many
things above all the principles of human
rights peace and justice and the love of
her community and constituency where she
grew up she was an exemplary MP a real
servant of democracy in every way one
could want or imagine what's happened is
beyond appalling we're here tonight in
silent memory of her loss and we express
obviously condolences to her family and
the statement that was put out this
evening by a husband
Brendan saying that we had to conquer
hatred with love with solidarity and
with support is one of the most moving
statements I've ever heard from somebody
so recently bereaved
I'm surrounded by parliamentary
colleagues particularly those who came
into Parliament with her in the general
election of last year of 2015 because
there's a special bond of newly elected
MPs the class of 2015 and they're
grieving deeply this evening for the
loss of one they admired one they loved
and one who had everything to live for
everything to give to all of us in our
society our democracy and our community
so we mourn and we're suspending all of
our campaigning activities until the
weekend as a mark of respect for her
and a mark of her humanity and her
determination to bring about the better
world that's what brought her into
politics that's what brought all of us
into politics
that's why we'll carry on remembering
her remembering all she gave I'm being
desperately sad tonight of the loss of
such a lovely woman who had absolutely
everything to live for this is a
shocking occasion and I hope everyone
realizes hatred will never solve
problems only people coming together
solves problems Joe believed that
Brendan believed that we believe that I
think I'm just grateful to everyone for
coming here tonight and all the
wonderful messages that have been sent
to the Labor Party and to her family and
to her constituents and all the people
there that have come in in the past few
hours as the shocking news is unfolded
thank you very much for coming this
evening